hey guys today is the twelfth of April
my name is just and here's what mattered
in video games today the Creative
Assembly have revealed their post launch
plans for total war warhammer the new
bits and pieces on their way are
separate from the two Warhammer sequels
which are also in the works the tab
explained in a blog post you can expect
a selection of content covering more of
the iconic good stuff you'll see in the
main game from new units offering new
tactical potential in battle to new
magic laws to augment certain races
spell-casting Arsenal you can also
expect to see the occasional new
legendary Lord who will shake up a
racist strategic potential in
interesting new ways last but not least
towards the end of the year we will add
a new playable race to the game
including new legendary Lords magic
items questions and units first of all
all of this will be free in terms of
paid DLC Creative Assembly added that
they do also plan to sell additional
Lord packs race packs and campaign packs
the details of which you can check out
in our story on site all the pricing is
yet we announced the former head of GTA
developer rockstar north is suing the
company saying he was forced out Leslie
Benzies claims he is owed 150 million
dollars in royalties as he was allegedly
forced out of the company after taking a
17 months sabbatical and these lawyer
explains while on sabbatical mr. benzies
discovered numerous deceptions on the
part of take to rock star Rockstar North
limited Sam Houser and dan Houser who
sought to force him out of the company
and terminate his portion of royalty
payments based upon arbitrary actions I
the company's royalty allocation
committee a committee that may or may
not have actually ever met the specifics
are as messy as you'd expect but
essentially the rocks are higher ups
were given access to a royalty plan and
there's some disagreement over whether
or not fans each has been paid all the
royalties he's owed now take two is
countersuing claiming benzies resigned
from rockstar without some good reason
so he isn't Oh Danny post-termination
royalty unless litigious needs Dark
Souls 3 is already frustrating but the
constant crashes on PC out bringing
plays to breaking point esteem thread
which is now 131 pages long and growing
has asked two games to write down where
the game crashed given the length and
number of contributions there seems to
be a lot of fairly significant problems
ranging from crashing at the first
bonfire to crashing during character
creation meaning the game can't even be
started there are a few workarounds
which presume the crashes are related to
the class you chose but so far bandai
namco appear to be simply suggesting you
contact their support team if you're
having trouble let me know down in that
comment section if you've been having
technical trouble with Dark Souls 3 you
can edge against that we've got stories
I'm the new destiny update and a new GTA
online mode that's everything I
graffitied a dude let me know what you
cared about and I will see you again
swear